another day and three more scandals
involving the current president and I'm
sort of struggling to keep up with it
all I'm gonna let you into kind of like
a problem that we're having here at the
show uh it's tough to know which
scandals to cover each day because I
have to prioritize number one covering
not only politics but also economics and
social issues and all of the other
things that we discuss on the show but
number two I want to make sure that the
audience is informed this is the Daily
Show after all I want to make sure that
the audience is informed about the most
relevant goings on with our elected
officials so when we learned that Donald
Trump confiscated and presumably
destroyed the only notes that existed
about a previously undisclosed meeting
with Vladimir Putin that's a big story
and that's the second story I'm talking
about today this goes back to the g20
summit of 2017 in Hamburg Germany but it
actually includes a total of five
meetings there are five meetings between
Donald Trump and Vladimir Putin for
which there are no records even
classified files don't exist for these
meetings and at some of those meetings
the reason why we have no record is that
Donald Trump personally confiscated the
notes from the interpreter who was in
the room for the meeting that's the one
where Trump met privately with Vladimir
Putin the meeting took place on the same
day that the New York Times published
that bombshell story revealing the Trump
Tower meeting had taken place and Don
jr. was there and a Russian lawyer was
there in the entire thing well we heard
now from Trump advisor and known serial
liar Kellyanne Conway who says that
Donald Trump didn't destroy the notes
from the meeting now consider what the
circumstances need to be for us to parse
that claim either that is a lie either
Kellyanne Conway is lying that the notes
have not been destroyed or she's telling
the truth as far as she knows it because
Trump lied to her and said the notes
haven't been destroyed or if it's true
basically Kellyanne Conway needs to have
personally seen the notes to confirm for
herself that they weren't destroyed
which would be really strange because
for Kellyanne Conway to be able to say
with
percent belief that those notes weren't
destroyed Trump would have had to have
shown her those notes at some point
which would be really weird that those
were just kind of hanging around
somewhere for Donald Trump to show to
Kellyanne Conway so everything about
this stinks something is very clearly
missing from this story Conway is
framing the confiscation of the notes as
a defense against leaks okay so the
argument there is when this meeting or
these meetings took place with Vladimir
Putin
the Trump administration and the White
House were suffering from a lot of
internal leakers and knowing this the
endlessly wise Donald Trump brilliant
stable genius Trump confiscated the
notes to prevent them from being leaked
okay I guess that's the argument she's
making we've also learned that Donald
Trump took the interpreter aside and
told the interpreter do not reveal
anything about what happened during one
of those Putin meetings and that is also
connected to one of the most important
timing elements of this entire thing
which is that the Hamburg Germany
meeting with Vladimir Putin happened
right before that New York Times
bombshell about Trump Tower and the
meeting with the Russian lawyer who's
now been indicted
Natalia vessel Mnet's kaya you'll
remember that on the way home from that
meeting Donald Trump dictated the
statement about Don juniors meeting with
Russians and Trump Tower which we now
know was a completely lie riddled mess
of a statement that Donald Trump spoken
to Vladimir Putin about it at that
meeting did Putin know that the New York
Times was about to publish such a story
did Putin advise suggest or direct Trump
about how to respond to it it's not
theoretical stuff it's practical stuff
now of practical importance these are
relevant details we would want to know
but unfortunately we don't know because
Trump confiscated and potentially
destroyed the only record of that
meeting that existed what do you believe
here Pat do you believe Kellyanne Conway
do you believe the simplest explanation
which is you
confiscate something you don't want to
ever have become public
not because of leakers but because of
the damning content are you not sure I'm
going to take the Occam's razor approach
and say that they just want it didn't
want this information to get out and the
defense against leaks argument doesn't
hold up at least in my eyes because the
only reason you'd want to destroy
documents so they don't get leaked to
the public is because there's something
in there that you don't want the public
to find out about and that it has to be
destroyed because there's something so
nefarious in there that you have to keep
it within the administration and it
would be really damaging if it got out
so this entire think stinks to me and I
definitely take the simplest solution
here yeah given everything that had been
going on with Putin and Russia at that
point in time if the notes about the
meeting contain nothing nefarious or
disturbing maybe it from benefits from
it being leaked and the further question
is why would anyone even want to leak it
if it's completely unremarkable in every
way and of course later that same night
at a dinner Donald Trump we now learn
sought out Vladimir Putin for another
meeting at which the only other
participant other than Putin and Trump
was Putin's interpreter which is against
basically all security protocol that I'm
aware of when it comes to dealing with
foreign leaders particularly ones with
countries that from countries that we
consider to be not particularly friendly
to the United States so I'm with you pat
every aspect of this thinks down to the
smallest detail we were remember
initially told that all of these
meetings were merely about child
adoptions we now know that that is a lie
so brazen and debunked that it's almost
laughable except we should be crying
rather than laughing because of how bad
it's gotten and down to the smallest
seemingly insignificant detail this
thinks something is very very much not
right here maybe we'll find out the full
scope of it in the next six to 12 months
send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show and we have some stunning
stunning video for you coming up after
the break one of the day's sponsors is
privacy dot-com slash Pakman which is a
free service that I myself use really
useful in many different ways takes just
a
few seconds to link your debit card to
privacy calm then you can create virtual
credit cards that are linked directly to
your bank account and you use those
virtual credit card numbers to buy
things online which protects your actual
debit card so that it's not spread all
over the Internet and one of the best
things about it is how their mobile app
and browser extensions for Chrome and
Firefox make it really easy to use let's
say for example that I'm signing up for
a david pakman show membership in the
credit card number field I already see
the privacy comm icon I just click it
choose which of my virtual credit cards
I want to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy calm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link